[Music]
the number one reason your startup will
fail is going to be a people issue
there's been several different data
collections on this topic and the
consensus across different researchers
is the vast majority of startups fail
one of the statistics is 9 out of 10
startups fail and no one Wasserman in
his book the founders dilemma
investigated through a series of
interviews and surveys why these
startups failed to achieve their stated
goals the vast majority of those
failures six of the nine failures were
people issues it was a fight between
co-founders the tour the company asunder
it was a lack of agreement about who was
gonna be leader between two founders
that kept the company from moving
forward it was a lack of culture they
created ongoing churn and an inability
for the company to scale if you think
about it and a start-up everything that
you do even choices which project you
want to make or how you're going to
pivot come back to people and the people
that you have in the room and their
ability to effectively make decisions
together and this comes from things like
diversity it comes from culture it comes
from emotional intelligence conflict
management skills in my mind and again
as a psychologist I am saying this
everything that you're gonna be doing
your startup is going to be about the
people and the sooner that you realize
that and you're as intentional about the
people choices you're making your
startup as you are about the product the
more likely you are to be that one
intense startup that actually does make
it and succeeds it becomes unicorn then
the rest of the world talks about
it's very competitive to find the best
talent and entrepreneurs often say well
I don't have money you know I'm never
gonna be able to get eight players well
guess what if you create an amazing
place to work this very mission driven
you actually can draw in the top talent
particularly the top talent has values
and ideas in line with your own and so
being very intentional from the get-go
after you have you know your leadership
in place idea what you want on the team
then also putting as much effort into
who are we as a company what does that
purpose for being we have our mission
that's never gonna change it's
democratizing manufacturing or you know
bringing financial knowledge to the
masses take your choice and then having
that vision of okay what's a really
amazing goal we could have five years
down the road the best goal is have
visions if you will have a 50% chance of
success and our visceral
say if creating beauty in the world is
your top value and you're accompanying
the springing artwork to companies and
then you're gonna be looking for how
that person brings Beauty into their own
life and not just how they tell you 101
but what are the actual behaviors
they've done of did they found a
non-profit organization to develop local
artists in their community you know if
you talk to their family where they
painting at a young age but it means
investing not just in what people have
to say to you when you're at a pitch
event which is they feel like often uh
founders fall into co-founding
relationships but you going slowly
enough before you apply a co-founder
title to get to know the people in this
person's life whether it's past
co-workers even family or friends are
really going to have different points of
data if you will on this person that are
as behavioral and concrete as possible
and not just something somebody can say
when they're being glib over a cocktail
whether you're leading a traditional
team or especially leading a start-up
knowing who you are and what you're
bringing to the table is so important a
lot of people don't dare to look within
enough to come to terms with those
strengths and weaknesses so
self-awareness is everything it's also
self-awareness in terms of your values
and what really drives you do in a
start-up because you want to do a
start-up I can almost guarantee you is
never gonna work doing a start-up
because there's a problem in the world
that speaks to your fundamental values
as a human person that's gonna work if
you talk to venture capitalists about
the type of co-founder they look for one
of the phrases they get back a lot is
magnetic and anybody can be magnetic it
depends if you found your passion you
found something in the world that deeply
means something to you
[Music]
you
[Music]